okay today we're going to do the labs
for chapter six um linear models and
regularization methods and uh we'll
start off um doing forward stepwise
selection but as always the first thing
we do is we import the libraries that we
need um for the lab and you'll be
familiar with this by by now there's one
little extra thing here there's a a
library we're not actually going to use
in this lab but notice this exclamation
install we install in a package on the
flyer and you see some
some um print out that that that follows
it um and so you can do that if you
don't have a package installed you can
just in the Jupiter notebook install it
on the fly so we did that just to
demonstrate
it but we're going to go to forward
stepwise selection and we're going to um
run forward step stepwise on the hitters
data using saler as the response okay
now there's a little problem here
because in the hitters data there's 59
rows that have missing values for
salary now when you do regression if you
have missing values in some of the
predictors or features you can do things
about that you can maybe put the mean
value in or you can do have ways of
imputing but if you got missing values
in the response you can't do anything so
you just get rid of them so we use the
we use a uh drop um na um method to get
rid of the the missing values in that um
data hitters frame and and now we're
ready to go and of course that reduces
the size of the data set by 59 cuz there
were 59 that were
there so in the chapter you learned
about using CP statistic to uh to do
model selection and uh CP is quite a
well-known statistic and uh so we're
going to do that here but the problem is
it's not built into it's not in SK learn
it's not in SK learn yeah so here we're
going to show you how if you have a a
metric that you you know a custom metric
that you like you can define a metric
you know using this kind of uh signature
and use the cross same cross validation
methods to tune with that metric yeah
here we use CP but you might have your
own for whatever purposes and that's a
great feature because that empowers you
if you've got your favorite metric you
can do it so here we write the function
and you can go through the details you
see the definition of CP in the chapter
and you'll see that's what we do in
there one little um catch is that SK
learn tries to maximize a score and so
um we want to actually minimize CP so
the function we right is the negative of
the CP statistic yes so that will that
will work
out now CP also requires in the
definition an estimate of the residual
variance Sigma squ so what we're going
to do there there and that's what's in
this code here is we just fit a model to
all the data and estimate Sigma squar
once and for all and and use that
estimate of Sigma squ using all the
variables okay and that that's standard
practice um using CP using CP yeah and
one little thing I'll just note if we go
and look up at the signature of NCP
maybe I can take the pencil for a second
the first argument is the sigma squar
which we have to set but the the metric
it should have a signature that takes an
estimator an X and A Y so we want to fix
this argument and that's what this
little this line here does it takes our
original estimator and fix the the value
of Sigma squar in it okay
so okay so now we're ready to go our neg
CP function can be used to do the model
selection so next thing we set up a
strategy for how we going to fit the
sequence of models okay and so that's
this this this chunk over year it
defines strategy as step uh stepwise
which is forward stepwise um first Peak
so that means it's going to run forward
stepwise until it reaches the the peak
until the in this case it's going to be
the the CP statistic negative CP starts
decreasing it's going to stop there so
that's where it's going to stop rather
than going through the whole function
although in this case actually we do we
do use all the terms right
yeah so actually in so in this one if
you look there's no we actually haven't
put in a score so we're actually not
using the ne CP uh it actually by
default is going to use something like r
squ or or or training msse in the next
example we'll have the next yes so in
fact we're not using first Peak so I
well we are using first Peak but not neg
CP so we will just use training sum of
square so if you allow it to go to the
end it will go it'll include all the
variables okay all
right um so now
um we set up our method and it's going
to be
using um SK learn selected on using OLS
as the fitting method with the strategy
that we've just defined okay and now we
actually we run it hits doore m.fit
we that's the function we use the fit
method using the hitters data and the
response y
and and we can extract the the selected
state which is a selected
model and what we get in this case is
all the all the variables because we
didn't we didn't tell it to use CP to
select so just selected the whole you
use training MSC as the as the score
yeah Ah that's so is that the default
that's the default or I it's either that
or R squ which you know will be you know
one to one functions of each other cuz
here we didn't miss specify a selection
strategy whereas next time we use it we
say score in is neg CP yes so if you
don't select it's just going to fit them
all so when we we do the fit um using
the scoring method over
here the steps are the same as before
what you see is a smaller subset of the
features that were selected okay so
that's selecting the model by CP
MH I think the next method that we're
going to use the same forward stepwise
but we're going to use um the validation
set in fact cross validation to select
the the model okay which is probably um
a more General method um and can be used
for any kind of
modeling so here the strategy is
stepwise fix steps because what we're
going to do is always use a full set of
um steps right and we're going to score
every single step and you'll see we're
going to make a plot afterwards that
shows the per performance as a function
of the step size that's right and again
the full path we Define as um using the
S method along with the strategy over
here and let's fit the full path on the
hitters data um and and so we do that
and so that will fit a sequence of
models um and and we also get we also we
call it the um y hat in we get
predictions on the full part
we give it the hit the hitters data and
it gives us back a matrix of predictions
so and what are The Columns of that
Matrix I guess they're the different
fitted values as the model grows yeah
yes that's right okay so there's there's
20 there's going to be 20 terms in the
model um the null that includes the null
model and and the 19 features added in
the importance one at a
time importance in terms of of residual
sum of squares right because this is not
using any scoring method that's
right so we want to make plots to to
show how these um mean squared error and
other measures um how they how they
decline as a function of or or change as
a function of number of steps so we've
written some code here for doing that
and you know the code sets the size of
the plot and sets the labels and so on
and we make the plot for our our first
sequence of models which is just using
mean squar eror and this is just
evaluate just on on the training data
itself subsequently we're going to look
at Cross validation and the validation
set method and add and compare them to
the just using the training table and
you'll see if you look at the code we
made we knew what sort of range we
needed because you can see this this
range is a bit bigger than we need to
plot this curve but we were anticipating
what we were going to see later on so
that they could all fit into the plot
yes now the other thing to note and of
course this has to be the case is that
the residual sum of squares is is
decreasing at every step because as you
add more variables you can only do
better in terms of mean squared error
and and residual sum of
squares
okay
um there's some details about uh about
how we we compute the residual sum of
squares and we explain we explain some
of them in the text here um but we won't
go over that now okay now we're going to
use kfold uh in fact fivefold cross
validation and we're going to use the SK
learn cross validation technology that
we've already learned in in in in lab
for chapter five yeah I think oh I
though Trevor I think there's actually
something new in this so we're using
this function if you look at it instead
of called cross validate which we saw
this one's called cross valve predict so
what that gives us is actually the
predictions um for whatever uh for the
um you know whatever the method is and
the cross validation it'll give us the
predicted value so on each fold you'll
get the the predictions having trained
on the other the remaining FS okay so
that's that's a function in SK Lo yes
yeah yeah and so that's why you the the
Yad CV has the same shape it's it's
actually all 20 cross validated
predictions okay so that's and that's
that's really convenient because
sometimes you want these prediction
matrices that have been predicted in an
honest way through cross validation and
you can compute any measures you like um
and uh in this case we are going to
compute mean squ
error
okay
so so in this in this chunk of codia
what we do is actually compute the the
mean squared error
this cross validated C uh prediction
Matrix has got 20 columns again and we
want to compute the mean squared error
for each of those columns but this will
be cross validated mean squared error
okay so in doing so what we do we do it
in two steps we first we compute this
Matrix here which is uh 20x 5 and that's
the cross validate the average error
inside each of the five folds okay
and so there's 20 different models
there's five folds for each we get a
mean squared error for each so why do we
do this we could have just computed the
average over everything well we want to
also compute the standard error and so
our final estimate of mean squared error
is going to be an average of these five
numbers and then we can have a AC crude
estimate of standard error for the
average so that's why we do that okay
yes and now we' having done all the work
we now add the cross validation estimate
to the mean squared error plot and this
is the code for doing that and there we
see the results okay and so it seems to
flatten out a little bit it's not
doesn't it shouldn't doesn't necessarily
have to drop of course like the the
insample one but it seems to flatten out
some you know and and you sometimes see
that and of course you have to take the
standard eras into account yes yeah but
uh you know if I were to look at this
plot Jonathan I would say maybe a model
with six terms is is a good is is a good
model to select yeah that looks that
looks faming yeah yeah and the standard
errors help us make the
selection
okay um we're also going to add to the
plot we're going to use we talked in the
in the chapter about the validation
approach where in the validation
approach you just set aside a training
set and leave some data as a test set
and so yeah we give code for doing that
yeah so I guess for this one we won't
get the same standard errors we did for
cross validation yeah we we had no
standard errors yeah um in fact so the
code looks pretty much the same and this
is the error on the validation set that
we get when you just have one validation
set now the interesting thing is this
validation set was randomly selected 20%
of the data now in the fivefold cross
validation they were also 20% the the
the valid the validation sets for each
fold was 20% % of the data MH so this
this guy seems a
poor a poor estimator compared to the
Cross validation because you only get
the benefit of one curve whereas cross
validation you do this five times you
get to average the curve and get a
better it should be more stable I would
guess and averages out the errors and
you get the and you get the standard
error yes okay so that's it um we're not
going to we're going to skip the best
subset selection and uh the next section
we're going to discuss is going to be uh
rid regression and lassu